candidata para ocupar el cargo de
primera ministra por parte del partido
nacionalista en sin fin tuvo motivo para
sonreír al cerrar su campaña en belfast
los sondeos de opinión han reportado que
el partido nacionalista irlandés se
impondrá en las elecciones legislativas
del jueves por primera vez en la
historia el partido que en su día fue el
brazo político del ira quiere ver la
reunificación de irlanda pero la
candidata a michelle o neill ha restado
importancia a las conversaciones sobre
un posible referendo en su lugar su
campaña se centró en los temas más
cotidianos
queremos invertir mil millones de libras
adicionales para arreglar nuestro
servicio sanitario queremos poner 230
libras en los bolsillos de los
ciudadanos para hacer frente a la crisis
por el incremento del costo de la vida
mientras tanto el partido unionista
democrático trata de atraer a los
votantes con una advertencia en contra
de un referéndum de unificación que
podría generar divisiones
el sinfín quiere trabajar en alianza con
los republicanos disidentes gente que
sigue ejerciendo la violencia gente que
ha cometido asesinatos en nuestras
calles de irlanda del norte
el rechazo al protocolo de irlanda del
norte por parte del partido unionista
democrático hizo colapsar el gobierno de
belfast en febrero creado por el
gobierno de reino unido y de la unión
europea para tratar los asuntos
comerciales cuando reino unido abandone
el bloque el partido estaba a favor del
bereshit pero no quedó contento con el
acuerdo final mientras que el 55,8 por
ciento de los habitantes de irlanda del
norte votaron por permanecer en la unión
europea los resultados finales de las
elecciones se darán a conocer el fin de
semana